in december 2019 the chinese authorities
notified the world that a virus was
spreading through their communities in
the following months it spread to other
countries with cases doubling within
days
this virus is the severe acute
respiratory syndrome-related coronavirus
ii that causes the disease called
covid19 and that everyone simply calls
coronavirus
what actually happens when it infects a
human and what should we all do
[Music]
a virus is really just a hull around
genetic material and a few proteins
arguably not even a living thing it can
only make more of itself by entering a
living cell
corona may spread via surfaces but it's
still uncertain how long it can survive
on them
its main way of spreading seems to be
droplet infection when people cough or
if you touch someone who's ill and then
your face say rubbing your eyes or nose
the virus starts its journey here and
then hitches a ride as a stowaway deeper
into the body
its destinations are the intestines the
spleen or the lungs where it can have
the most dramatic effect
even just a few coronaviruses can cause
quite a dramatic situation
the lungs are lined with billions of
epithelial cells these are the border
cells of your body lining your organs
and mucosa waiting to be infected
corona connects to a specific receptor
on its victims membranes to inject its
genetic material
the cell ignorant of what's happening
executes the new instructions which are
pretty simple copy and reassemble
it fills up with more and more copies of
the original virus until it reaches a
critical point and receives one final
order self-destruct
the cell sort of melts away releasing
new corona particles ready to attack
more cells
the number of infected cells grows
exponentially after about 10 days
millions of body cells are infected and
billions of viruses swarm the lungs
the virus has not caused too much damage
yet but corona is now going to release a
real beast on you your own immune system
the immune system while there to protect
you can actually be pretty dangerous to
yourself and needs tight regulation
and as immune cells pour into the lungs
to fight the virus corona infects some
of them and creates confusion
cells have neither ears nor eyes they
communicate mostly via tiny information
proteins called cytokines nearly every
important immune reaction is controlled
by them
corona causes infected immune cells to
overreact and yell bloody murder in a
sense it puts the immune system into a
fighting frenzy and sends way more
soldiers than it should wasting its
resources and causing damage two kinds
of cells in particular wreak havoc
first neutrophils which are great at
killing stuff including ourselves
as they arrive in their thousands they
start pumping out enzymes that destroy
as many friends as enemies
the other important type of cells that
go into a frenzy are killer t cells
which usually order infected cells to
commit controlled suicide
confused as they are they start ordering
healthy cells to kill themselves too
the more and more immune cells arrive
the more damage they do and the more
healthy lung tissue they kill
this might get so bad that it can cause
permanent irreversible damage that leads
to lifelong disabilities
in most cases the immune system slowly
regains control it kills the infected
cells intercepts the viruses trying to
infect new ones and cleans up the
battlefield recovery begins
the majority of people infected by
corona will get through it with
relatively mild symptoms
but many cases become severe or even
critical
we don't know the percentage because not
all cases have been identified but it's
safe to say that there is a lot more
than with the flu
in more severe cases millions of
epithelial cells have died and with them
the lungs protective lining is gone
that means that the alveoli tiny air
sacs via which breathing occurs can be
infected by bacteria that aren't usually
a big problem patients get pneumonia
respiration becomes hard or even fails
and patients need ventilators to survive
the immune system has fought at full
capacity for weeks and made millions of
antiviral weapons and as thousands of
bacteria rapidly multiply it is
overwhelmed they enter the blood and
overrun the body if this happens death
is very likely
the coronavirus is often compared to the
flu but actually it's much more
dangerous
while the exact death rate is hard to
pin down during an ongoing pandemic we
know for sure that it's much more
contagious and spreads faster than the
flu
there are two futures for a pandemic
like corona fast and slow
which future we will see depends on how
we all react to it in the early days of
the outbreak
a fast pandemic will be horrible and
cost many lives a slow pandemic will not
be remembered by the history box
the worst case scenario for a fast
pandemic begins with a very rapid rate
of infection because there are no
countermeasures in place to slow it down
why is this so bad
in a fast pandemic many people get sick
at the same time
if the numbers get too large healthcare
systems become unable to handle it
there aren't enough resources like
medical staff or equipment like
ventilators left to help everybody
people will die untreated
and as more healthcare workers get sick
themselves the capacity of healthcare
systems falls even further
if this becomes the case then horrible
decisions will have to be made about who
gets to live and who doesn't
the number of deaths rises significantly
in such a scenario
to avoid this the world that means all
of us needs to do what it can to turn
this into a slow pandemic
a pandemic is slowed down by the right
responses especially in the early phase
so that everyone who gets sick can get
treatment and there's no crunch point
with overwhelmed hospitals
since we don't have a vaccine for corona
we have to socially engineer our
behavior to act like a social vaccine
this simply means two things
not getting infected and not infecting
others although it sounds trivial the
very best thing you can do is to wash
your hands
soap is actually a powerful tool the
coronavirus is encased in what is
basically a layer of fat
soap breaks that fat apart and leaves it
unable to infect you
it also makes your hands slippery and
with the mechanical motions of washing
viruses are ripped away to do it
properly wash your hands as if you've
just cut up some jalapenos and want to
put in your contacts next
the next thing is social distancing
which is not a nice experience but a
nice thing to do this means no hugging
no handshakes if you can stay at home
stay at home to protect those who need
to be out for society to function from
doctors to cashiers or police officers
you depend on all of them they all
depend on you to not get sick
on a larger level there are quarantines
which can mean different things from
travel restrictions or actual orders to
stay at home
quarantines are not great to experience
and certainly not popular but they buy
us and especially the researchers
working on medication and vaccination
crucial time
so if you are put under quarantine you
should understand why and respect it
none of this is fun
but looking at the big picture it is a
really small price to pay
the question of how pandemics end
depends on how they start if they start
fast with a steep slope they end badly
if they start slow with a not so steep
slope they end okayish and in this day
and age it really is in all of our hands
literally and
figuratively
a huge thanks to the experts who helped
us on short notice with this video
especially our world in data the online
publication for research and data on the
world's largest problems and how to make
progress solving them check out their
site it also includes a constantly
updated page on the corona pandemic
[Music]